good afternoon everybody my name is Matt
Harvey I'm the executive director of the
Stanford Technology
ventures program and on behalf of the
Faculty of etl Tina Seelig and Tom Byers
like to welcome you to our session today
just a couple of quick notes again thank
you all for being here
we've always want to make sure to make
shout out to Draper Fisher Jurvetson and
their support of the series at dfj it's
I've been a huge help to us over the
years to make these talks happen so
we're grateful for that and also if
you're interested you can see this talk
in a week from now and all of the other
talks we've done in the years past at
our Stanford a corner website which is e
corner dot stanford.edu we just
relaunched it this week so please check
it out and let us know what you think we
appreciate it
our guest today is Amy Chang and she's
the co-founder and CEO of a company
relational intelligence firm that's kind
of creating a AI products for
professionals and leaders she received
boats both her bachelor's and master's
degrees here at Stanford in electrical
engineering she was also one of our
programs early Mayfield fellows which is
terrific she's had product and strategy
roles at eBay she spent some time at
McKinsey and also had a very prominent
run at Google for more than a decade
working on ad products and analytics
products and kind of being the global
product head for those as well she also
sits on a number of boards you're very
busy on that side as well as some fairly
prominent firms such as Cisco and
Procter and Gamble and we're super
excited to have her back here so please
help me welcome her back to Stanford
so I mentioned you know you were
electrical engineering major
why did you study that were you always
passionate about the discipline or is
that something you found when you got
here so I actually was on scholarship
and there were four choices on
Electrical Engineering was my favorite
of the four choices so rolled that way
do you remember the other choices yes
they were Chemical Engineering materials
science and mechanical cuz Intel paid
for school for me school so they were
kind enough to do that and one of the
four disciplines that they were a
proponent of was Electrical Engineering
then it was fantastic
now when you were back here for the
Masters as well and even in your
undergrad time tell me a little bit at
that point you know what was the
entrepreneurial environment like on the
campus were you always kind of aware
that you were interested maybe someday
and working at a start-up or founding
something or how did you find that here
on our campus I don't think it was like
it is today I mean it's um much more
kind of widespread and pervasive even in
mainstream media today to be an
entrepreneur and to pursue those
opportunities and I think in 99 and 2000
and Ravi you can correct me if your
perception is different I don't feel
like it was quite as as pervasive and so
for EE in particular many of us would go
into hardware companies right after
school but it wasn't really as much of a
thought process to say oh you know let
me start my own and it wasn't until you
know 12 13 years into my career that I
thought I might be interested in doing
that and I don't think I would have had
the confidence coming straight out of
school so kudos to those people that do
because it's it's such a great
experience
you know we've even some of our faculty
have done research over the years on
sort of Stanford alums and a number of
them that really very high percentage
that end up in startups or early-stage
companies was there did you ever feel
any pressure to be in a start-up or do
you see that and we sometimes hear that
from students now like you know am I
going to go work for the right company
should I be starting my own thing
well I hear that all the time from
either candidates or folks were kind of
mentoring right and people feel a lot of
pressure they feel like oh if I don't
take advantage of the opportunity now
what am I going to have this opportunity
again and I I think it's something that
has become a pressure that that folks
feel but I will say this you have plenty
of time and decide when it's right for
you to start something decide
it's right for you to join something
because a career is a very long-lived
thing and often it's very serendipitous
and people always ask also did you have
a ten-year plan I'm like I don't even
have a two-year plan let alone a
ten-year plan let's take it six months
at a time people cuz you know it's crazy
out there so you just kind of take it
take it as it comes right and analyze
each opportunity and the framework of
where am I now and what do I want most
immediately and what do I want next you
have your advisor to firms as well do
you see sort of those pressures play out
and the I'm sure you get a number of
people pitching you an idea or coming to
you just to spit ball something and
things like that do you sense in that in
their pressure where does that come from
does it sense of keeping up with the
Joneses here in the area or do you think
it's just some internal driver that they
have that they have to do that
I think they've gotten here in the first
place there's all your very motivated
and very strongly driven and there are
things that you wanted out of you know
your life and your career and there are
things you wanted to learn and that bar
is high right so you see you know the
person in your dorm kind of deciding to
start something or you know half your
graduating class let's say from CS
deciding to go to startups of course it
gives you internal pressure I don't see
how you would be human if it didn't give
you a little bit of internal pressure
but that doesn't mean you have to go
that way
it just means you take a step back and
you recognize oh I'm feeling this
pressure where is it coming from
right you were a early member of the
Mayfield program and things like that
how did you discover it and what was
attractive to even to the idea of it
because it was pretty early then it
didn't have a reputation maybe it has
now yeah it's um so I knew two or three
people who had been in the two classes
or three classes before me and they just
raved about it and it they said it was
basically life-changing which had
changed my trajectory as well I wouldn't
have gone to McKinsey straight out of
school if not for her Mayfield and so
after hearing about it from these two
three people I think it was Steph Hannon
and a couple others I kind of thought
okay well just I'll go take a look and
I'll interview and if I get in then all
I'll think about it and I'll decide and
if I don't then you know then I won't
but then you know look at it and it kind
of went from there from me and it's a
few years back to reflect on a little
bit but are there
that from that educational experience
because it's somewhat different than
just a very standardized class that you
still kind of carry with you or kind of
things that came out of that you say you
know that kind of has stuck over time
you know I'm sure it was shaping in ways
that I did not realize I didn't even
know what a business model was before I
got into Mayfield I didn't know what a
supply chain was I didn't know what any
of those terms meant and it was very
eye-opening to get kind of a sketch of
the business side and to understand that
there was a whole realm of things which
having done EE and been immersed kind of
in hardware and network systems for five
years that I didn't even have a
conception of which I'm sure all of you
are much more sophisticated today and
already have kind of a better handle on
that but I feel like it was very
eye-opening at the time it's interesting
we've we've had the pleasure at our
program of working with students from
all over the country at different
universities different contexts a lot of
students internationally which is quite
interesting to the dynamics of it but
one thing that always seems to hold up
is students are in the midst of this
experience which is so formative and
there's so much to do I mean it's an
opportunity rich environment I don't
actually know a Stanford student that's
not sort of overextended in some way
all right whether it's classes or
activities or clubs or something that
you know there's always seems to be
there's a little bit more to add to the
plate at the buffet you look back on
that now
what do you wish you had spent a little
bit more time doing what if you could
refocus or reallocate that time now what
would you have spent it on I I think I
would have been more deliberate about
spending time with those people that I
sat in class with that I thought oh my
gosh that person is smart right or that
person seems so crazy capable I would
have spent more time building my network
even then because those are the people
who you know 20 years from from when
you've graduated have gone on to do some
amazing things and you have the
opportunity they're literally sitting
two tables down from you right now or
they're across the hall from you in your
dorm and so when you find someone that
is a little bit fascinating or just a
little bit kind of you feel like oh
there's some chemistry here I would
carve out time for it because you
studying and
you know doing kind of all your problem
sets and and everything that you need to
do all the obligations that you have of
course you you want to do well but I
would carve out an hour or two every
week or two to find somebody new who you
thought was interesting and make the
time to actually get to know them
because you'll see later five ten
fifteen years out
they will have done amazing things and
you will be glad you took the time so
clearly that's an excuse to just pass on
the problem sets just build
relationships or get a nice mix going
that's a totally okay that's in a
permission from an alum yeah you know
you've worked at you know the company
should work at before you know eBay and
Google you've had these really
interesting kind of formative
experiences I mean McKenzie I imagine
you got to see inside lots of firms
through a different kind of portal what
did you find culturally about places
like eBay and Google and maybe others
especially because you were at them at
places where there is this still this
sort of trajectory and scale going on
culturally how are those cultures
similar and and what did you learn from
those two well I'll share a practical
story because I think a lot of you are
gonna decide on summer internships or
you're gonna decide on jobs within the
next couple years so one thing that I
was found helpful when I was leaving
eBay
I had offers from Yahoo and from Google
and the thing that I did that I think
really helped me make my decision
because at that point in 2005 Yahoo
Google were still neck and neck
obviously the story has changed since
then but back then they were still
pretty pretty comparable in many ways so
they won't let you in the building
because they're security but they will
let you sit outside they can't stop you
from sitting outside so I went in sat
for two hours outside of Yahoo and I sat
for two hours outside of Google and I
watched people's faces because I wanted
to understand how are they interacting
with each other what do they look like
when they're talking to each other what
do they look like when they're walking
from meeting to meeting do they look
happy
do they look as if they want to be there
and they want to talk to each other and
I just wanted to see what I could
discern about the environment from
watching people interact with each other
as they were were doing this and going
about their day and I think that was
what made my decision more than kind of
anything else because at the time Yahoo
was willing to pay more they were
willing to give me a team they were
willing to do
stuff that Google just wasn't willing to
do but there was something visceral
about how Google felt to me when I was
on the campus and watching people's
faces and so I would advise you if
you're going somewhere to interview go
early they can't stop you from just
sitting there and observing while nobody
knows kind of that you're a candidate
yet or that you're there for anything
and just watch and see what you think
and how you feel about it because that
gut instinct call I think you'll find as
the years go on that it should be heated
at least fairly often that's a great
story in the sense of actually being
able to pick up any kind of
environmental factors so often people
come into an interview sequence
something they have no understanding of
it except outside of this room and it
feels pretty isolating and doing you
give a true sense of it I actually like
to sometimes when I'm there for board
meetings at Procter & Gamble or Cisco
I'll just sit and work for an hour or
two before kind of the board meeting
starts because I I want to get a feel
for how things are feeling and to take
the temperature that's really
fascinating did you find once you were
inside Google that the experience there
was you know it's we've had a number of
folks who have had Google experience
over the years here at the series but
what did you take away is sort of a
pattern of it that either impressed you
or surprised you about the way that
place operates it's so unique from so
many other places in the world so the
first time after we launched Google
Analytics to kind of out of beta and
into the real world we went back and I
think we had 2.7 percent market share or
something and we were so proud that we
were on the map now and we said okay and
by the next kind of quarterly Business
Review with the executive team we will
have 9 percent market share and we were
like nine percent that's triple that is
so huge and we're really excited to
express this and Larry basically said
come back to me when you have a plan for
70 percent market share and don't come
back to me saying 9 percent like that's
chump change you figure out how to get
to 70 and that was that was kind of game
to you because we're not in no place in
our heads had we gone to majority market
share like thoughts right and we were I
mean the the system was still falling
over sometimes
and our site reliability engineers we're
still waking up every single night and
having to reboot machines and get us
back up and run it was like behind the
scenes there was some stuff going on
right so we weren't thinking about the
70% market share but when somebody
pushes you so far beyond what you
thought was possible and forces you to
think at an another kind of level of
ambition if you will then you would have
by yourself I actually think that's a
really good thing to experience and it
makes you deeply uncomfortable for a
little bit you have no idea how you're
going to do it but that's how you grow
and that's when you experience your most
massive jumps and growth I think is that
something now you've carried to a
company and in the way you want to
excite your team and excite the leaders
as well did you get to have the 70% I'm
sure it annoys the living daylights out
of them sometimes but yes yes do you
find folks push back up against it or do
they seem confused by it like how do you
guide leaders that you're people you're
grooming to really kind of the leaders
inside the firm know how do you get to
that I think you are explicit ahead of
time to say I'm gonna set the
expectations at a place where I don't
expect you to always meet them but I
expect them to be high enough to where
you push yourself into the yellow where
you're not in the green anymore where
you're completely comfortable you're not
in the red where you're so stressed you
can barely see straight to right there
in the yellow where 3 out of 5 days
you're gonna learn something totally new
that you did not know in the morning
when you woke up and by the end of the
week you will have gotten further than
you thought you would have gotten on
Monday morning when you first came into
work that's a good week that sounds a
lot like the description of the life of
an entrepreneur in general kind of
living in the yellow I do how do you you
know is it is it our people you find
people you've worked with that are
constantly in the red and they're
they're under the gun all the time and
then there's other folks kind of slow
rolling it in the green if I'm
understanding your scale there how do
you how do you find the right balance
for yourself as an individual as a
leader running a whole group in that way
I there are some weeks when you know
things are in the red so Cisco and
Procter & Gamble had board meetings back
to back one week and it was those a
little bit of a crazy week and it will
happen again in December so those weeks
are a little stressful but you just you
you deal with it and
and yeah you you keep going and not
every week is red so that's the good
part right how do you describe a company
like can I ask a question how many of
you here feel like you operate in the
yellow now where you're challenged
enough to where you don't know
everything you need to know for that
week and how many of you feel like you
know that's a place where you're
operating now where you're in the yellow
okay that's fantastic this is the beauty
of Stamford right is most people are
operating in the yellow so if you do
feel like you're in the red and you're
drowning a little bit you just saw the
other people who are in the yellow
leaned on them for help because there
are everybody I think feels overwhelmed
sometimes and like they're operating the
yellow even people who look perfectly
polished and put together they're in the
yellow so don't don't feel as if you're
isolated there in the yellow poke the
person next to you and I'm you know
somebody else somebody will talk to you
about it and feel the same way so lean
on each other a bit when you first
started to ask the question at the hands
didn't go up quickly and I was concerned
that we're all gonna say red like I was
like or they are red and they don't want
to admit to red but that's a whole other
thing yeah by the way guys if you have a
question throughout this feel freeze
raise your hand jump into this as well
Amy I am sure pretty gonna be fine with
that as well please I have time at the
end as well but feel free to pop in yeah
the whole point is to be useful to you
guys that is the the whole idea so
anything you have please please ask it
so a company is now about four years old
roughly how would you describe the
culture and I guess that's the wages you
could tell me the way you would describe
it to a perspective higher but or how
would you just described it as the CEO
so there are number one value and excuse
the cursing in class is no and
you have to be willing to hire and fire
by that right you have to be willing to
say oh my gosh this person is really
really bright and they could be a
phenomenal technical talent on the team
they're just kind of an so we're
not gonna hire them and that's it's a
hard lying to hold right because it's
tempting to say oh but they're really
really brilliant but we as a team and as
a company have decided that we want to
want to work with everybody on the team
that doesn't mean everybody's cookie
cutter and the same and etc but it means
that people have consideration for other
people and respect
for other people as they work with them
right doesn't mean all the same
personality type so there's
communication differences but we don't
want somebody who fundamentally lacks
respect for other people and doesn't
treat everyone as a human being should
be treated so that's the line and then I
actually think Reed Hastings said
something fantastic I don't know if you
guys have seen his culture manifesto
it's it's actually quite good to look at
especially if you're thinking of
starting your own company I think he
wrote it four or five years ago at this
point a long time ago but it still has
held held up very very well and in it he
basically posits that the culture should
be real enough and authentic enough and
in some ways gritty enough to repel
people though the wrong people for that
company as well as attract the right
people for that company and I I do kind
of share that belief right if it's all
kind of apple pie and you know rainbows
and unicorns then it's it's not real
enough to be kind of strong enough and
cohesive enough to both attract and
repel which i think the culture you
should be honest about what you are and
what you are not so that the right
people come in and the people who are
not going to find it to be a place where
they thrive find it a place where they
will thrive which is not your company
it's interesting concept in the sense of
you know some people come into an
interview situation and I think it's a
one-way street but it really is this two
way you know I'm hiring you you're
hiring me do I want to spend my time
here yeah have you had situations where
you maybe you've done your best to set
up a culture that they can clearly sense
a signal about where they should be
maybe they set outside for two hours
before maybe they picked up a little
thing how do you have you had a
situation where you've hired somebody
it's clearly not as advertised yeah
perhaps on the individual once they're
inside there cuz they just really wanted
to get inside the company yeah how do
you manage that is it just it gets
quickly as much as you can but you have
to let them go right because the effect
that they have on the rest of the team
and the other members of the team that
are working so hard to create a place
where kind of people want to be isn't
it's not a good effect so I think that's
your job as a leader to figure out when
is it time and to do
in as fair and as humane a way as
possible and if you can help them
understand what they are looking for as
well and what's going to suit them well
all the better five you've referred
people who haven't worked out for us
into other companies like there was
someone who was better suited to be at
Google than they were at a start-up and
any startup they just they wanted a lot
of structure and that's it a startup
just isn't the best place for extreme
process and and structure right so we
found her a place to go mister does the
one of the things that sort of
interesting we're at this sort of moment
in not only in society but here in the
valley very specifically having really
important long long long overdue
conversations about who's in the room
whether that's the boardroom or the
c-suite or rank and file folks that are
coming part of the company's my
understanding is that probably about 60%
of the executives or maybe more than 50%
of the whole company or women that work
at a companies that's correct yeah how
did you build that in or is that just
picking the most talented people or do
you guys have tactical things you do to
make sure you're getting good balance in
the team's that end up working for you
you know it's funny we didn't actually
do anything that deliberate or different
I think when one of the founders is
female and the CEO is female that helps
where people feel like oh I would
probably be welcome to interview there
I'd probably be welcome in the
environment there and I think it it
builds on itself so having the female
role models whether in the executive
suite were on the board at each company
I think it actually is important because
who's gonna talk to you during your
interview who's gonna answer those
questions who's going to kind of role
model that yeah we care about diversity
here we we care about diversity of
thought diversity of gender diversity of
race etc so I yeah I think that's
extremely important you know how long
totally were you at Google the ten
twelve years eight and a half years 18
have years okay so eight and a half
years you are doing incredibly well
there you have a large portfolio of what
you're we're taking on and the teams
you've built what's the thinking when
it's time to step away from something
like that yes
various decision I probably ever made
for me right I am make us through that a
little bit so when you're at a place
where you've kind of grown up right and
you've been there for long enough to
where if a lot of friends there have
kind of grown up in the same cohort
class with you you know how things work
in the company you know who to go to for
what and the biggest thing is you're
attached to your team because you build
that team and by the time I left my team
you know was a few hundred folks and I
had hand-picked many of those folks and
I loved them and so I didn't want to to
leave them but at the same time when
you're eight years into somewhere you
ask yourself am I a lifer and is this
what I want to do for the rest of my
career or like what is happening here
what do i what do I actually want and if
there is something where when you close
right before you close your eyes to go
to sleep and right when you open them
when you wake up in the morning if you
keep finding yourself thinking about
something we're thinking to yourself I
should be happier why am I not happier I
should I should be more grateful for
what I already have and if you find
yourself kind of thinking about an idea
or thinking about a possibility pay
attention and maybe write it down for
yourself and go back and look
longitudinally across a few weeks
because you'll find that your gut
instinct or your your kind of sense of
what you want is already there you just
may be a little afraid to act on it and
so now I try when there's something that
keeps coming up for two weeks or more I
already know I gotta act on this and
this is something that is bothering me
and I just need to change it but this so
I probably woke up at 2:00 a.m. to three
times a week for a couple months before
I finally decided that I was going to
resign and then they they made it hard
to resign it's a fantastic place right
and it was I think my husband who
finally said okay you have already made
up your mind you need to stop waking me
up and you you already know what you're
doing so just go in let her know you'll
do it well you guys will still be
friends and it'll be fine right
and yeah I finally I finally went in and
just resigned and it was I didn't end up
resigning right then it took another six
months but that was the beginning of the
process so I have since learned if
something
is in there for a couple weeks I got to
pay attention to it it's eating at you
it won't let you go and things so how
long after Google did you could spot the
opportunity that you're pursuing now and
take us through a little bit of like
what you saw and why you'd want to
dedicate so much your life to it so my
co-founder I met at Google two weeks in
to - coming - to starting Google and he
is an MIT CS PhD he won the ACM his year
he's amazing and he's just a great human
being and he had just gotten citizenship
and so we were celebrating it we were at
dinner and he basically turned to me and
he said do you still want to start
something together and I kind of went
yeah I would love that and he's like
okay I'm ready I know that way he's very
understated
he's like I'm ready and I kind of met
now you're ready and he's like yeah I'm
ready so we both decided within a few
weeks after that to to leave and to
start this and then we are very lucky
and got a five million seed and just
started so that's kind of how it
happened he just it was time I I
described a company briefly up front but
do you want to take a moment and kind of
explain it to everyone here what that is
and how you I'd love to so our mission
is to change people's career
trajectories long-term like the the
whole point is to bring you something
and let me explain something just very
quickly so I grew up in Texas in Austin
where our entire network was like 19
other Chinese people that we hung out
with every weekend so I did not
understand the importance and this is
why I talked to you guys earlier about
the importance of the network and the
importance of investing and getting to
know people you find interesting or you
find fascinating when you don't have
time because it bears fruit in such
unexpected ways later and I'm on the
boards that I'm on because of our
product because two people Chuck Robbins
and David Taylor the CEOs the Cisco and
PNG respectively we're using our product
how does serendipitous moment and we're
asking okay well who made this that's
how I ended up on those boards and the
exec headhunters were using our stuff so
anyway long story short I guess the
point is
so I didn't understand the importance of
network when I came to Stanford only
probably five years into my career did I
get it and so now what we're trying to
do is bring this data and this
intelligence together to serve it up to
you on a silver platter to make it so
easy it would be silly not to stay in
touch with these people that come and go
in your life because they will be the
ones who will pull you up later or push
you up later right but that whole that
whole kind of serendipity of a career is
all about serendipity it is all about
people knowing what you do appreciating
what you do and recommending you for
things that's how opportunity occurs
that's in some cases the only way you
ever find out about certain
opportunities so the more you take the
time to get to know people and to really
genuinely get to know them but to allow
them to get to know you too the more
people can be kind of recommending you
and looking for opportunities for you
right and that's the piece where I
really wanted software to enable that I
really wanted to to have that be
something where people like me who did
not grow up with that concept and who
didn't understand the importance of it I
wanted to be able to accelerate their
career by 5 or 10 years or 15 years but
by a substantial amount so that they
could experience this opportunity much
much earlier but how can you in a
different way tell people yes Meyers but
going to all the events learning
something else networking is all a
little bit oh sure I can
I can restate that so how do you balance
between you know when you have a limited
number of hours in the day how do you
balance between going to these events
and all of this and your schoolwork and
making certain the grades stay high so
that you can get into grad school etc
etc right is that the question so I
actually really am NOT a huge fan of big
events where you meet 40 people for five
minutes i i'm not memorable enough to
where you would remember me after
meeting me for five minutes so i kind of
don't think that that's the playing
field that i want to be on the playing
field i want to be on if we're in class
together and there's 20 people on let's
say it's a sip class or something and
you say something so interesting to me I
think to myself I don't have lunch with
that woman what is she thinking when
she's you know when she's saying these
things that's so interesting I will ask
you to lunch because I actually want to
get to know you and I will invest that
hour if you will to get to know you
because I actually think you said
something super interesting that's how I
would rather do it I'd rather take a
walk with you I'd rather have coffee
with you I'd rather have lunch with you
and that's I find that and if you pick
let's say one a week at the end of the
quarter you've gotten to know ten people
probably two of those will stick right
but then if you accumulate that over a
10-year period does a lot of people and
that's how I would prefer to do it
instead of doing the events and you can
fit that into your schedule around all
of the other obligations you have from a
schoolwork point of view please question
is a founder I'm keen to understand
people you mentioned you were lucky
you've got the five million dollar
candygram as a founder that's very lucky
so the original concept was a
relationship management kind of tool
right and the thing is at the time
LinkedIn's api was so open Facebook's
API was still open everything was still
completely open and available and then
about a year into the company's lifetime
LinkedIn shut down the API Facebook kind
of pulled back on their API by quite a
bit
we had a big decision to make whether or
not we would create the data platform
ourselves and it's actually one of the
most fun parts is creating the data
platform but Dave Goldberg was a good
friend and we sat down together and Dave
basically said if you don't create this
data platform yourself you don't have a
business right it's not a
business it's an acquisition it's not a
business and we we talked about it and
he basically said you have to dig the
moat and the only thing that's going to
give you the moat is the data you cannot
depend on somebody else for that and he
actually said I will give you fifteen
million dollars to build this data
platform and I really think you should
do it so I went back and I talked to my
co-founders we talked about it for about
a week
and we decided to take the money and
that was our a round and iconic led that
with Dave but we basically since then
have built this data platform that is
three hundred million profiles and
twenty million company profiles and we
look for kind of digital exhaust
everywhere so anytime you speak anywhere
so Matt you've you know let's say you go
and you speak at Ted we'll grab the
speaker bio we'll NLP it into its
component pieces and it's so much easier
to edit and then it is to author right
so then all you have to do is come in
and edit your profile we don't even need
you to edit your profile because we're
dipping all the time as we find new BIOS
for you on the web and then what we're
doing is for any professional who's on
the system we're prepping the briefing
for them ahead of time so when we sit
down together I already know your
context I understand your company and
your company's financial performance but
I understand any news about you I
understand any tweets you've had I
understand
kind of who we might have in common so
that I can open with that right but the
the system now is self learning and it's
92 percent accurate without any human
intervention which has been so
fascinating to build and it's it's the
team that's done all of that but it now
has allowed us to do things like
predictively say okay so in any given
company here are the people we see as
kind of rising stars whose careers have
pulled a standard deviation up off of
the cohort norm and they're moving
faster right here are the super
connectors who sit between industries
and can cross pollinate between
different industries so if you're
looking for someone in your industry to
bridge you into this other one here's
this person that might be really good
for you to meet with so these are the
types of
of kind of insights and analyses you can
do on top of this massive data platform
[Music]
I had a network and that's how the five
million happens right people have to
know you they have to trust you they
have to know what you've done in your
career and it's all risk mitigation so
any venture capitalist has LPS they're
responsible too and they have to be
responsible stewards of that money and
so as much as you can mitigate risk by
understanding what the DNA of this
founding team is and what they have
credibly done before in their careers
then you can feel more comfortable
investing more or less accordingly right
so again that's why the network is so
important
besides this sort of kind of moat moment
where it was sort of like very clear
that you had to build a business around
this but yeah doing they did a platform
really fun really cool really hard yeah
so what are some of the things that I
mean that's clearly a surprise in this
sort of four years of time what have
been a couple of other things or one
thing that you go this was completely
unexpected this is not something that we
every week there's anything that's
unexpected that's part of the fun of it
right but are you are you asking from a
kind of business standpoint a question
in that sense I think one of the
questions you always ask yourself is
what talent do you need to bring on wet
right and when things take off you're
suddenly caught they're thinking oh my
god I need to hire this person yesterday
and if you become so urgent about that
hiring you lose sight of either the
culture point or you know one of the
other kind of core things that's
important in bringing on a new person to
the team you could hire someone that
it's expedient to hire instead of being
disciplined and waiting because it's
painful to wait I mean you're you
yourself are doing two or three or four
jobs so you're very tempted to bring
this person on so holding that line is
yeah if you go on the wrong side of that
line is painful done do it is that the
same sort of situation then in regards
to product strategy cuz there's you sort
of scale up how big is a company now so
we're about 40 people about 40 people so
just
lightly too large to yell across the
room you know I think I do famously
could put 40 around in one meeting and
then it finally busted out or something
like that
what is how do you maintain sort of
product vision in a way that stays pure
or does it have to just be handed off to
people in some way and say you know
we're not all gonna be on the same page
all the time oh my gosh that's the
hardest part as a founder especially as
a product founder is knowing when to
step back and let go a little bit ben
horowitz give me some phenomenal advice
he basically said you need to start
writing everything down
you can't expect things to be
transmitted just by talking anymore
you're gonna have to start to be more
formal about it and start to write more
down and be more disciplined about it
and I think it was very good advice I'm
still working on that but I think it was
very good advice when you look at sort
of then the competitive landscape I mean
what what is even about you know there's
just a pure love of the of the
technology on some levels - what is
exciting to you about artificial
intelligence just generally as a field
because that really is you guys are in
there and in a specific space and
there's so much the public has a
perception of what that is it's it's
still so new they don't really science
fiction in so many ways for so many
people what is something that you love
about it and you find fascinating and
maybe something that the public
completely misunderstands about this I I
think the scale that you can achieve and
the experimentation and kind of the
unexpected results and being able to
automate so much and have it have it
just cost a lot less to do things that
are very far-reaching and scaled has
been a serious pleasure as a founder
because you spend less money after kind
of you get things tuned the right way
and things are able to run by themselves
right it's much more cost effective to
do something massive like build a data
platform and there there is a competitor
which I think they have five six million
profiles in their their stuff and it
costs them $1 to $2 to generate each
those profiles because they have to do a
lot of it manually it's a point zero
zero one sense for us it's the cost of
storage and compute because we
have created this engine that is that
has discernment and patterning on its
own so that's this the scale you're able
to get has been fascinating that seems
like a very strong network effect in
your favor are there do they are they a
possible acquisition it's important
especially that kind of cost that's
pretty challenging yeah as a thing you
know part of this was also as a start-up
founder there's this move now and I
think this has changed a lot in the last
10 20 years you know the sort of older
idea of well you know great job founder
you got it at this point time to bring
in adult supervision or higher
professional operators to do this but
this trend and the last decade really
more of lying founders to stay with the
firms for longer and kind of I think
there's some sort of sense of that
they've been able to create a pure or
true innovation culture how do you know
if you have a culture that is
legitimately innovative because everyone
says it it's a buzzword if the words
lost meaning now how do you what what do
you see inside and it's a small company
get a large comfortable both actually
there'd be great so at a large company I
feel like if in fact anyone at the
company feels as if if they have a good
idea somebody will listen and it can go
somewhere without it being a Sisyphean
task pushing a boulder up a hill that's
when you know you have an innovative
culture as a large company because
otherwise it's very easy for people to
feel like I have an idea but I'm not
gonna express it because it's it's not
gonna go anywhere nobody's gonna listen
it's gonna be such a pain in the ass for
me to to get anybody to do anything with
it that is a non innovative culture and
I think a lot of large companies
struggle with that right because there
is resourcing there's bureaucracy there
are layers and layers that can say no
and there's very few people who can give
a blanket yes and green light for a
project the larger the organization gets
and as a small company you better
innovate or you're gonna die I mean it's
like it's pretty binary right either
you're innovating or you're you're just
gonna run out of money and die so that
one that one's pretty easy the large
company one is is the more complex one I
think did you find that you know is
interesting you mentioned that the no
rule I think anyone who's been
to class all this glory for all the
cursing no I you're not the first
in fact I'd say most weeks this quarter
we've heard that phrase actually
including Bob Sutton who was earlier
part of that is also around when it gets
to these large organizations the
friction the policies the the the the
road to hell you know paved with good
intentions around why we do these sorts
of things are at forty people now do you
feel are you already feeling creeped in
that way and then what do you do to kind
of not yes I I think it tends to happen
right around 75 to 100 that's what I
have seen and it can happen at any stage
if you're not careful
right but yeah I I think we'll get there
at some point but we're not yeah yes
it's interesting you also in your
background about having been an advisor
and now having a number of board seats
you've had experiences now I guess
sometimes people see it as both sides of
the table or something like that what is
in your mind what is your job as a good
board member to ask questions right it's
really to ask questions because you
don't know the day-to-day operations
like the management team does you don't
you're dropping in for a couple days a
quarter you may meet with members of
management in between but really your
job is to ask the questions they may not
they may be too close to ask for
themselves and as one of the board
members with less-experienced who's
younger right your your job is to ask
the questions that come into your head
as questions that are germane to kind of
the company in terms of innovation in
terms of how they're thinking about
their two-year five-year ten-year
product strategy all of that but you're
gonna come with a different point of
view and they actually brought you on
for that point of view so when they
bring you on they actually want you to
ask the questions that you have
yeah that's it's basically your job and
then formally your fiduciary duty to the
shareholders is to make certain the
right CEO is in place because the CEO
then makes the other management team
decisions this is sort of a fascinating
note given recent events and news as to
the are we do we have the right CEO and
the seat at any given moment yeah do you
find so put yourself back in the role of
a CEO mm-hmm
you're bored what throws you when you
interact with them what do they bring or
how do they want you to be behaving or
or working with them that that's such a
unique relationship depending upon how
bored people take seats whether they
came from investors or whether they were
just great kind of independent folks
what is the the right mix of that or
does it depend entirely on the company I
actually there's a point I would make to
all of you who are going to found choose
your board members carefully because
it's a seven to ten year relationship
right it's a long term relationship so
it's not just the money they bring but
is this the person you want in the boat
when this stuff hits the fan is this the
person you want to be seeing every you
know month to two months across the
table for seven to ten years do you like
this person enough to do that and I I
think the weekend before taking the term
sheets for our seed round I actually
called 26 CEOs because I wanted to
understand what did it look like when
you failed with this investor what did
what did their face look like then when
things were not going well did they stay
with you in the boat did they abandon
you did it did it get ugly how did it
look and I think that at talking to
founders who have failed with that
investor will tell you far more than
almost anything will about them and so
when you pick this person pick carefully
because they're with you for a long time
and having a fair-weather friend in that
position is not a nice place to be so
having somebody who has the experience
and has the gumption to stay with you
when you know as you go through kind of
all the ups and all the downs is pretty
important so she's choose carefully and
do your homework before you choose
someone well i won't name the the
Stanford alum founder but there was a
comment once made that a board is sort
of like having five or six PhD advisors
at the same time and you owe all of them
money like right the weight on you is
this guy sort of mixed issues you're
feeling at the same time yeah I want to
make sure I open up a chance to anybody
have questions chance nope right up
two percent accurate are there any good
stories only 4% in the a percent
sometimes you look and again apologies
for the the cursing we've cluster new
kins right so someone's name John Smith
how many John Smith's are there kind of
on the web there are a ton of John
Smith's
so sometimes you get somebody clustered
and you know someone's husband is named
John Smith and they send in a ticket and
they're like this is not my John Smith
and there's funny stories so yes an
every percentage point you have to fight
for above 90 right every percent it's
gonna be a dogfight and there's not
silver bullets above 90 its lead bullets
but it's fascinating kind of the the
problems that you get to solve because
they are hard hard problems so yes there
are lots of funny stories where you know
people are confused especially the very
common names because we're frequency
patterning on the names appearing kind
of as strings together and yeah there's
there's some funny stories yes eating
the team and building it and when you
give criticism and start offenses when
you're eating the most important factors
make sure that the person is on board
and comes out of it after we're not up
to it so one of the things I like to do
before I have to give really hard to
feedback is I'll go back there's a book
called please understand me and it
sounds cheesy but actually edition one
is better than addition to if you're
gonna get it
and it's by Kirstie Bates and it's old
like it's been around forever
but I like to remember what myers-briggs
type the person sitting across from me
is if they're an introvert or if they're
sensing versus intuitive or if they're
judging versus perceived like what is
their frame of reference and when I
communicate with them how are they
likely to interpret what it is I am
saying and I will actually alter my
communications so that they are more
along the lines in the stylistic lines
of that person's communication style
because they'll be much more receptive
to my message that way especially if
it's a difficult one
so I will go back and reread and I will
sometimes ask that
to read my myers-briggs typing so they
don't misinterpret when I say something
because I tend to be very direct right
so I'd like for them to understand that
I'm coming from a place of very good
intentions and that I'm trying to help
so if you frame it right before the
discussion in terms of this is your
communication style this is mine this is
where we're likely to have friction and
this is where we're likely to
misunderstand each other that framing is
already in their head which I find very
useful but you want to study how a
business works in a different company as
you're in your first job how would you
compare a small start-up and they start
up like Airbnb Google it depends on what
you want so if what you want is to
figure out and to be adjacent to the
founder experience and to understand
kind of all of that in a more
accelerated way so to give it this way
the faster you want the ride to go the
smaller you go right because you'll be
buffered from far less and the other
thing about a smaller place is you'll
have to wear a lot of hats which if you
want to found yourself you actually want
to wear as many hats as you can and take
on as much responsibility as they will
give you and in a smaller high-growth
place you'll just have more white space
around you that you can expand into
where there's nobody there yet saying
hey that's my space don't go in right
concerns plenty of space for everyone so
if if I was gonna found something in a
few years I would go smaller because I
would want to be as adjacent to the
founders as I possibly could and learn
as much as I could as fast as I could
what would be okay I just see many
people just go to a larger company
because if you work in a smaller startup
this then it's harder to get into a
larger scheme and work and see how that
organization operates I you know I would
say the war for talent is so real right
now you have much
more leverage than you think you have
much more leverage and don't be afraid
of what doors will close when you choose
something you would be surprised how
life works if you work hard and people
understand kind of your impact what what
doors open up that you never would have
expected so focus on this next closest
step and knocking it out of the freaking
park for this step because doors will
open that you never expected as you do
that every step of the way just knock it
out of the park people will see it
they'll recognize it and they'll start
talking about it and things will just
happen from there I mean you're hiring
all the time we're hiring you see you
can tease folks with a career there yeah
yeah we're saying it right now but I
mean you would not you would look at a
track record like that and see not
problems but see somebody who was
wanting to dig in yeah not it's not a
problem you interview them you sit down
with them and right away yeah this
person is yeah they're they're real and
they're intense etc so just curious like
we're not a social network we're the
data platform with insights on top of it
and so we waited until the data platform
was rich enough to your exact point we
waited till it was rich enough to where
people like Chuck Robbins would find a
lot of value in it and so the second we
gave it to them we ingested their
contacts and stuff and then there was
just a super rich news feed right away
already
right and they didn't have to lift a
finger they didn't have to tune the
system they didn't have to connect with
anyone or enter anything it was just all
automatic because we were clustering
their contacts with the people entities
that we had and kind of you know
creating that feed for them and their
calendar and their briefings and all of
that so you didn't have to lift a finger
so to your point it's really important
to bring value within the first 30
seconds of when someone's using you
I'm catering you take so many different
role of course both for director in your
own CEO comes that is to for time job
right like how do you are Nancy are in
wait do you like dependencies my
neighbor things on next week and how you
actually you know the flavor is
automatic to your team and people around
right because so many much demand your
time grinder family to people who work
for YouTube yeah so I on Sunday nights
will sit down and kind of do my planning
for the rest of the week and I find that
that is extremely helpful the other
thing I have found that helps me because
I'm urgent about everything is
meditation in the morning so I used to
make excuses like oh you know I'm but
I'm in such a rush and I have a son
who's 10 and I I just you know I don't I
don't want to miss time with my son in
the morning
etc etc so now I just get up 20 minutes
earlier and I actually take the
disciplined time to meditate because it
makes a difference in my team they can
tell kind of when I've meditated right
I'm a lot more patient and and I lived
in a lot better so in on days when you
know I let's say I had a 7:00 a.m. call
or something and I didn't quite get
there for the whole twenty minutes I can
tell they can tell but I think for
anyone who is more myers-briggs judging
versus perceiving meditation is a great
thing for your team and a great thing
for you but yeah the weekly planning on
Sunday nights has really helped a lot
too and then every once in a while if
you put a block into your calendar say a
four-hour block alright once a quarter
to where you don't talk to anyone you
don't bring devices you just bring a
notebook and you sit somewhere and you
ask yourself the fundamental questions
of am I missing anything
is there anything I haven't thought
about that I need to think about and are
there macro things that are gonna affect
my business and my company that I have
not given enough thought to and carve
out that kind of strategy time that's by
yourself I think that's important to do
too
what's your opinion on the future of
jobs with the predicted or already
happening rise in AI so I don't I don't
think it's all that original or
different from what's already out there
in the mainstream media I don't have any
kind of two standard deviation off
opinions on what's gonna happen there we
need to obviously rescale a large
portion of our workforce and how we're
going to do that and who's going to pay
for that is a is a big question right
and kind of the the functional house
versus what are we going to do I I feel
like that hasn't been answered yet and
there's a lot of smart people working on
it which is good and the dialogue on it
has risen to a point where I think
enough people are starting to realize we
need to do something which is great let
me ask a follow-up on that there's you
know this ongoing conversation right now
about Silicon Valley and we are so
driven to create new and interesting
things and then we set them free in the
world and then a couple years later we
go oh we hadn't anticipated that that
would be an issue yeah what is the role
of companies from an ethical standpoint
to build in some ability to prevent
against that you might carry insurance
in the in the old-fashioned way it would
be you know a brick and mortar place
that's where integrity and ethics comes
into play and that's it's so hard to
regulate right and that's where a
company's culture comes into play that's
where the integrity of the individuals
who make it the decision to release that
technology into the wild and to to have
thought about it ahead of time and to
have tried to understand the
implications of their actions it's so
important but how do you regulate that
how do you and you govern that how do
you enforce compliance on that it's such
a Harry Harry question you see it's sort
of an autonomous there were some
questions over there so I just wanted to
make sure that there were a couple hands
raised I think over here is did people
get calls other goals oh go so famously
like you said really ambitious goals
yourself and I'm just really cool I try
and do this thing but my question she
would be let's say we set our goals in
this guy we don't get quite there but if
you get close how do you justify that to
the team or how do you frame that how do
you tell someone in ambitious goal with
them maybe knowing that you don't expect
them to ah so this is the part that
Google did so well I think the point is
to put the ambitious goal that is it is
so ambitious that our okay ours the
objectives and key results at Google you
only ever expected to get a point seven
you never expected to get a one you
always only expected to get a point
seven and people would start gaming the
system knowing that you know you expect
to get a point seven your performance
was based on that etc but still the the
one would be such an outsized one that
the whole point is to force your
thinking into a different plane and then
two for the team to work as hard as they
possibly can to get there but for it not
to have been necessarily an achievable
goal all of the time and if it were an
achievable goal all the time that would
indicate that it's not ambitious enough
right but then to celebrate when the
team does reach kind of the 70% level to
have the judgment to know when to
celebrate and to make certain that
people feel appreciated for yeah what
they did so it sounds like culture and
people are so much so important to
success knowledge in AI and in the back
yes yes as this part I've finished
you're involved you're going this or
doing a point art and Georgie how do you
smell and filter for people to have
flexible mindset and rigid mindset so
that you don't get people who come in
and stake something you could call off
the entire machinery the best
interviewing guide I have seen to test
for fixed mindset versus growth mindset
is actually by Adam grant so he's a
Wharton
I think behavioral science professor but
you can look it up and he basically says
don't ask people theoretical questions
ask them about times when they have
actually looked
they encountered something that was
extremely challenging and it felt as if
it was Oh the odds were overwhelmingly
against them and what they did and keep
digging and keep asking why why why why
right and try to get down to their base
motivations and what makes them them at
their very core and I think the method
in which he coaches you I actually go
review this interview guide fairly
frequently because I want to remember
exactly how he asked the questions but I
would go look at it it's Adam grant but
it's a phenomenal one because it just
the way he poses the questions puts
people in the the right mindset to
express and then he tells you what
you're looking for one last question
who wants last last take
anything there we go
let's see you but in college right now
well you said we just to take a look
engineer I would just guess I just yes
because the software is eating the world
so I I would do see us and I would
probably do a subspecialty nai well
everybody thank you please help me thank
Jamie for this wonderful
[Applause]
you